You have to be intelligent to be creative. Can you really learn to be more creative? In this episode, we speak with one neuropsychologist who studies intelligence, creativity, and brain function. He talks about why, even if it sounds counterintuitive, intelligence and creativity may not have all that much in common. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Rex Young is an assistant professor of neurosurgery at the University of New Mexico, and a practicing clinical neuropsychologist in Albuquerque. He studies both brain disease and what the brain does well,
你必须聪明才能有创造力。你真的能学会变得更有创造力吗？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位研究智力、创造力和大脑功能的神经心理学家。他谈到了为什么尽管听起来有悖常理，但智力和创造力可能并没有太多的共同点。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。雷克斯·杨是新墨西哥大学神经外科助理教授，也是阿尔伯克基的一名执业临床神经心理学家。他既研究大脑疾病，也研究大脑的优势功能，
a field of research known as positive neuroscience. His research is designed to relate behavioral measures, including intelligence, personality, and creativity to brain function and structure. He's published research articles across a wide range of topics, including traumatic brain injury, lupus, schizophrenia, intelligence, and creativity. Welcome, Dr. Young. Thank you, Audrey. Could you, first of all, explain neuroimages?
这是一个被称为积极神经科学的研究领域。他的研究旨在将行为指标（包括智力、个性和创造力）与大脑功能和结构联系起来。他发表了涵盖广泛主题的研究文章，包括创伤性脑损伤、狼疮、精神分裂症、智力和创造力。欢迎您，杨博士。谢谢你，奥黛丽。首先，你能解释一下神经影像吗？
and tell our listeners how it helps researchers understand how people think and act? Sure. So neuroimaging is the tool that we use to measure the brain, and there's lots of different neuroimaging techniques. I use three main neuroimaging techniques. The first that I learned in graduate school was magnetic resonance spectroscopy, which sounds kind of complicated. But it is a technique that basically looks at the chemicals in your brain.
并告诉我们的听众它如何帮助研究人员了解人们的思维和行为方式？当然。神经影像学是我们用来测量大脑的工具，有很多不同的神经影像技术。我使用三种主要的神经影像技术。我在研究生院学到的第一种是磁共振波谱分析，听起来有点复杂。但它基本上是一种观察大脑中化学物质的技术。
It's in a standard MRI machine like you would. would go to get your knee scanned. But using some sophisticated techniques, you can look at certain chemicals in the brain. Some of those chemicals are very involved in important neuronal processes. And we've correlated those with behavior. A different technique is called diffusion tensor imaging,
它是在标准的核磁共振成像机中进行的，就像你去扫描膝盖时那样。但使用一些复杂的技术，你可以观察大脑中的某些化学物质。其中一些化学物质与重要的神经元过程密切相关。我们将这些与行为联系起来。另一种技术称为弥散张量成像，
which allows us to look at water movement in the brain. And this is important because there's lots of tubes going through your brain, like the wires that connect up your computer to the internet. And these tubes, called axons, are connecting up different processing modules of your brain, and those have to be healthy. So we can look at the health of those axons, those myelinated axons, the fatty shees, like the insulation, that surround those tubes.
它使我们能够观察大脑中的水分运动。这很重要，因为你的大脑中有很多管道，就像连接电脑和互联网的电线一样。这些被称为轴突的管道连接着你大脑中不同的处理模块，它们必须保持健康。因此，我们可以观察这些轴突的健康状况，即那些髓鞘化的轴突，以及围绕这些管道的脂肪鞘（就像绝缘层一样）。
The third technique that we use is just structural magnetic resonance imaging, and that allows us to look at the processing modules of the brain, the cortical thickness, the computers that are on the surface of the brain, and how much or little of that you have on the surface of the brain. Those are the three main techniques that I use. There's functional imaging, fMRI that most people have heard of where you're looking at blood flow as well. Those are ways that we measure brain structure and function, and this gives us the ability
我们使用的第三种技术是结构性磁共振成像，它使我们能够观察大脑的处理模块、皮层厚度、大脑表面的“计算机”，以及大脑表面这些结构的多少。这就是我使用的三种主要技术。还有功能性成像，即大多数人都听说过的功能性磁共振成像（fMRI），你也可以观察血流。这些是我们测量大脑结构和功能的方法，这使我们能够
to do scientific measures that then we can correlate to behavioral. measures in psychology. Does being highly creative mean you're also more intelligent? Not necessarily. There's a controversy about this in the psychological literature, and some people have found correlations between creativity and intelligence. They're usually pretty low, this association, and some people make a lot of that, this low association. But usually because this association between creativity and intelligence is low, it means that you don't necessarily have to be intelligent to be creative. So I spent over a decade studying intelligence.
进行科学测量，然后将其与心理学中的行为测量相关联。非常有创造力是否意味着你也更聪明？不一定。心理学文献中对此存在争议，有些人发现了创造力和智力之间的相关性。这种关联通常很低，有些人对这种低关联大做文章。但通常因为创造力和智力之间的这种关联很低，这意味着你不一定非要聪明才能有创造力。所以我花了十多年时间研究智力。
It's one of the reasons I started studying creativity because it seemed like something distinctly different and interesting than intelligence, which I had studied. I work with very highly intelligent people in academia and scientists, and not all of them are creative. Why is that? If they do go together, I would be working with all of the creative people in my city in Albuquerque, but that wasn't the case. So creativity seemed to be something different. And can a person learn to become, I mean, after you've been studying all this, can a person learn to become more creative or simply gain intelligence? There's some tools and techniques that can help people to be more creative. We're starting to learn more about creativity.
这是我开始研究创造力的原因之一，因为它看起来与我研究过的智力截然不同且有趣。我在学术界和科学家中与非常聪明的人一起工作，但并非所有人都具有创造力。为什么会这样？如果它们是相辅相成的，我应该会和阿尔伯克基市所有的创意人士一起工作，但事实并非如此。所以创造力似乎是不同的东西。那么一个人能学会变得更有创造力吗？我是说，在你研究了这一切之后，一个人能学会变得更有创造力，或者仅仅是获得智力吗？有一些工具和技术可以帮助人们变得更有创造力。我们开始更多地了解创造力。
and it's one of the things that I'm excited about in terms of creativity is that there might be ways to increase your creative capacity. Intelligence, unfortunately, seems to be much more under tight genetic control. The genetic correlates of intelligence are high, like 0.75. So if you have twins, they're going to be identical twins. Their correlation of their intelligence with one another is going to be very, very high. So that implies that the genetic involvement of that capacity is under much more tight control than the environment would be. With creativity, we don't have that information, and I'm hopeful that you can modulate or modify creative cognition much more than intelligence.
关于创造力，我感到兴奋的一点是，可能存在提高创造力的方法。遗憾的是，智力似乎受到更严格的遗传控制。智力的遗传相关性很高，大约为0.75。所以如果你有双胞胎，他们是同卵双胞胎，他们的智力相关性会非常非常高。这意味着该能力的遗传参与度受到比环境更严格的控制。对于创造力，我们没有这方面的信息，我希望你能比智力更有效地调节或改变创造性认知。
There are studies out there that have shown increases in intelligence scores, of two, maybe three points on a particular measure, which are not particularly high, but those are also controversial. Some have been replicated, some haven't been replicated, and we really don't see that in terms of intelligence. With creativity, there's a pitched effort to try to increase creativity scores on some of these measures, and we're seeing some good initial results, and I'm very hopeful about that. How does the way a person's brain works and is structured influence how creative or intelligent he or she is?
有一些研究表明智力分数提高了两到三分，这在特定指标上并不算特别高，但这些研究也存在争议。有些已被重复验证，有些则没有，我们在智力方面确实没有看到这种情况。对于创造力，人们正在努力尝试提高这些指标上的创造力分数，我们看到了一些良好的初步结果，对此我非常乐观。一个人的大脑工作方式和结构如何影响他或她的创造力或智力？
The research that we've done shows that the brain organization of intelligence and creativity are quite different. So when you think about those measures that I talked about, those neuroimaging measures, the brain of someone who's intelligent think of bigger, better, stronger, faster. All the measures are pointing to high. higher integrity of the brain of someone who has high intelligence. So the cortical mantle is thicker, the white matter, the wires are more myelinated, the water can travel faster and in a coherent direction. You have more of these certain chemicals that I was talking about.
我们所做的研究表明，智力和创造力的大脑组织方式截然不同。当你想到我谈到的那些指标，即那些神经影像指标时，聪明人的大脑可以被认为是更大、更好、更强、更快。所有的指标都指向高智商者大脑的高度完整性。所以皮层地幔更厚，白质（电线）髓鞘化程度更高，水分可以更快地向一致的方向移动。你拥有更多我刚才提到的那些特定化学物质。
It's beefed up. It's beefed up, yeah. So you can have a better organized brain. With creativity, the story was different. In different regions of the brain, we were seeing weaker, connections, thinner cortex, and different levels of these same biochemicals. So it was really clear from these studies that intelligence and creativity were different because we were seeing different pictures in the measures we were taking in the brain. But I tend to look at creativity
它被加强了。是的，被加强了。所以你可以拥有一个组织得更好的大脑。对于创造力，情况则不同。在大脑的不同区域，我们看到了更弱的连接、更薄的皮层以及这些相同生化物质的不同水平。因此，从这些研究中可以清楚地看出，智力和创造力是不同的，因为我们在大脑测量中看到了不同的图像。但我倾向于将创造力
intelligence as two different kinds of reasoning, that creativity is kind of reasoning without all of the information presence. So call it abductive reasoning. But you have hypothesis testing about how the world could work without all the information present. So you have to use abstraction and metaphor and stuff like that about this might look like this or this might be this way. With intelligence, you're using deductive reasoning where it's rule-based reasoning. A equals B and that's the way it goes. You have a rule for how this relationship works. So creativity and intelligence are probably different types of reasoning. Both are very adaptive, but they're just different. for different types of problems that you have to solve out in the world.
和智力视为两种不同的推理方式，创造力是一种在信息不全的情况下进行的推理。所以称之为溯因推理。你在没有所有信息的情况下，对世界如何运作进行假设检验。所以你必须使用抽象和隐喻等方式，比如“这看起来可能像这样”或“这可能是这样”。对于智力，你使用的是演绎推理，即基于规则的推理。A等于B，事情就是这样。你有一个关于这种关系如何运作的规则。所以创造力和智力可能是不同类型的推理。两者都非常具有适应性，但它们只是针对你在世界上必须解决的不同类型的问题。
Is real creativity rare? How about genius? So creativity is common and genius is a lot more rare than we would believe. The term genius gets thrown around a lot. But I think genius is rare because that combination of brain organization where you have high fidelity, beefed up brain in certain regions, and then kind of down-regulated brain in other regions, is really going to be kind of rare, where that is present in the same brain. So to have that back and forth between intelligence and creativity,
真正的创造力罕见吗？天才呢？创造力很常见，而天才比我们想象的要罕见得多。“天才”这个词经常被滥用。但我认为天才之所以罕见，是因为那种大脑组织组合——即在某些区域拥有高保真、加强的大脑，而在其他区域则表现出某种下调的大脑——在同一个大脑中同时存在是非常罕见的。因此，要在智力和创造力之间进行那种来回切换，
the ability to do both of those reasoning processes well, where you can do first approximations, hypothesis testing, abstraction, and then create a rule, a novel and useful rule out of nothing before is rare, and that is true genius. Great. Thank you so much for joining us. Dr. Young. It's been very, very interesting. Great. Thank you, Audrey.
即能够很好地完成这两种推理过程，能够进行初步近似、假设检验、抽象，然后从无到有创造出一个新颖且有用的规则，这是罕见的，那才是真正的天才。太棒了。非常感谢您加入我们，杨博士。这非常非常有趣。太棒了，谢谢你，奥黛丽。
Thank you. For more information on Dr. Young's work and to hear more podcasts, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。欲了解更多关于杨博士工作的信息并收听更多播客，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。